[Música]
muchas gracias por permitirme estar aquí
hoy en mi alma máter y contarles un poco
quién soy pero sobre todo
qué pasa con cal y en materia de paz en
materia de reconciliación yo me imagino
que muchos de ustedes si no la mayoría
somos caleños
y a veces no estamos muy conscientes de
qué está pasando afuera en las calles
que pasa en el distrito de aguablanca
por ejemplo qué pasa en la ladera se nos
pasó la historia se nos ha venido
pasando la historia y no necesariamente
nos hemos dado cuenta de los avances que
hemos dado
miremos lo que hay atrás de mí
todo pasa y ha pasado en cali
nosotros fuimos la casa matriz de uno de
los carteles más grandes de la droga en
el mundo eso deja huella y eso genera
efectos y eso lastima y eso la cera y la
cera cultura y las heras sociedades y la
cera dinámicas
nosotros somos la única ciudad del país
que ha tenido tres secuestros masivos en
el marco del conflicto llegaron de
manera cinematográfica al corazón del
centro administrativo de nuestra ciudad
y se llevaron a la corporación
departamental en pleno 11 diputados pero
ese fue uno de los muchos secuestros
esa imagen que ustedes ven allí esa
bomba si ustedes observan con atención
el edificio que está atrás es el campo
es el centro administrativo municipal
en este momento tal vez ya se nos olvidó
que estará la realidad que vivíamos
estás imágenes de estos chicos
todos los días las seguimos teniendo
tenemos cualquier cantidad de comunas y
barrios bueno no cualquier cantidad no
menos unas 11 comunas en condición de
extrema vulnerabilidad
al interior de cada comuna hay entre 20
y pueden haber 30 o más barrios llenos
de fronteras invisibles llenos de niños
y jóvenes armados siete años yo me
imagino que muchos de ustedes habrán
visto 'ciudad de dios' y habrán dicho en
algún momento dios mío eso como puede
pasar pues pasa y pasa en una ciudad
como la nuestra pero además de eso
además de narcotráfico conflicto armado
y sus efectos violencia y dinámicas de
violencia que nos rodea el conflicto que
nos estaba describiendo ahora juliana y
que decía 52 años muchos de nuestros
compatriotas de un bando y de otro
matándose de manera permanente dejó en
víctimas el mismo número de habitantes
que tiene un país como israel 8 millones
8 millones son muchas personas
constituyen un país y aquí las tenemos
pero en víctimas
en personas afectadas en hombres y
mujeres que perdieron todo la dignidad
la libertad la vida su propio cuerpo sus
tierras todo por lo que trabajaron lo
que nos ha dejado la guerra es doloroso
es muy doloroso y a veces cuando estamos
aquí en una universidad cómodamente
sentados en nuestras casas pues no somos
necesariamente conscientes de todo lo
que pasa afuera y de toda la cantidad de
seres humanos y de compatriotas que
nuestro a nuestro alrededor necesitan
oportunidades pero también terminamos
convirtiéndonos
en quienes vamos viviendo el día un día
a la vez y se nos olvida la historia y
se nos olvida la memoria y se nos olvida
que hoy estamos mejor que ayer estas
imágenes que ustedes están viendo por
ejemplo a mí realmente me impactó mucho
ver la imagen de la bomba al lado del
centro administrativo municipal porque
dentro a ese edificio todos los días de
mi vida y entró ese edificio todos los
días de mi vida porque en el año 2016
una persona tomó la decisión de darle a
cali un impulso de otro nivel en materia
de paz y de reconciliación esa palabra
que está tan politizada esa palabra que
pareciera ser que si es de santos que si
no es de santos que si la quiere uribe
que si no la quiere uribe entonces no la
queremos etcétera etcétera
un derecho que tenemos todos los
colombianos en este caso y la tenemos
por constitución y no es otra cosa que
la posibilidad de vivir y de convivir en
armonía sin matarnos no es otra cosa que
la posibilidad de relacionarnos los unos
a los otros respetando la diferencia y
cuando yo les digo que me impresiona ver
la imagen de la bomba la vi cam porque
trabajo en el campo se los cuento porque
resulta que no entiendo muy bien cómo y
se los digo con honestidad
me convertí en la secretaria de paz en
la primera secretaria de paz de este
municipio
eso para mí en este momento además de
ser un honor es una responsabilidad
inmensa porque estoy en mi ciudad y me
acaban de dar cuando digo me acaban
estoy hablando en tiempo relativo la
responsabilidad de dejarle a mi ciudad
una alternativa de transformación que
sea sostenible y duradera en el tiempo
ya eso me ha dedicado los últimos tres
años si me ayudas
hace 4 años largos empezó a sonar por
todos lados paz paz paz que bueno que es
malo que nos gusta que no nos gusta que
le pertenece a este que no qué
pero resulta que se nos olvidó
en qué consiste realmente el término el
concepto
nosotros tenemos como ciudad la tasa más
alta de homicidios de colombia eso es
una cifra alarmante es una cifra que es
inadmisible que no tiene lógica alguna y
tenemos la tasa más grande de homicidios
en colombia porque somos una ciudad con
unas características muy particulares
aquí en cali solo en cali hay más de 200
mil 205 mil víctimas del conflicto
armado han llegado y llegan todos los
días hemos sido una ciudad de tránsito
de ex combatientes de grupos armados al
margen de la ley desde hace 16 años
cali recibe desmovilizados si ustedes
han ido yo me imagino que todos han ido
alguna vez al éxito de pronto se han
encontrado con un desmovilizado de
pronto un desmovilizado les ha facturado
la cuenta en la caja una persona que
hizo parte de las farc
y cuando la vemos en la caja pues no se
nos ocurre pensar que es un monstruo
y cuando yo me acerco a esa realidad
hace más de diez años largos once años
largos la vida me dio la posibilidad de
empezar a trabajar en temas de paz de
desarme desmovilización de reintegración
empiezo a encontrarme con que los seres
humanos que portan armas en mi país
muchos empezaron a aportar las siendo
niños muchos otros
ahí tienen una condición de venganza muy
marcada muchos otros se estaban
simplemente muriendo de hambre y
quedaron entre dos fuegos es decir
quienes han hecho parte de las lógicas
del conflicto en colombia son
colombianos en la mayoría de los casos
muy pobres en un porcentaje muy alto más
del 65 por ciento menores de edad
y eso no solamente pasa y pasó en el
conflicto armado sino que pasa y está
pasando en el conflicto urbano
nosotros llegamos a los barrios y nos
encontramos niños y jóvenes que no
entienden que la vida puede estar más
allá de defender una línea imaginaria de
microtráfico que es lo que los provee a
ellos ya sus familias de recurso
económico y ahí es cuando entonces
empezamos a creer
que hay que
ser creativos valga la redundancia y
pensar de qué manera generar
transformación
o garantizando que se cumplen con todas
las condiciones que el estado de manda
necesita y requiere y ahí nos damos
cuenta de dos cosas la primera la
resocialización de un ser humano de un
individuo pasa por una oportunidad y la
segunda no necesariamente nuestras
dinámicas sociales de conflicto van a
cambiar a punta de cárcel
porque porque la cárcel no es
resocializadora y no lo estoy diciendo
yo lo dice la literatura en el mundo
a menos de que tengamos cárceles del
estilo de los países nórdicos
definitivamente que un joven o un niño
de nuestro de nuestra ciudad ingrese a
un contexto este caso penitenciario no
garantiza que ese joven ese niño va a
salir a ser un mejor ciudadano al
contrario el factor de riesgo de que ese
niño y ese joven salga a seguir
delinquiendo y a delinquir más es
altísimo es de más del 80 por ciento
y resulta que empezamos a descubrir cómo
darle la mano preguntarle con un
acompañamiento permanente no preguntarle
un día preguntarle de manera permanente
y sistemática cómo estás que necesitas
cogerlo de la mano y llevarlo y decirle
mira si tú aprendes a leer y escribir se
abren estas posibilidades
cogerlo de la mano y decirle mira esta
es la ciudad esta escala porque muchos
de nuestros jóvenes que están
delinquiendo nunca han salido de sus
barrios y de sus fronteras invisibles de
ahí también un ejercicio de
territorialización fuertísimo las
protegen como si fueran sus propias
casas
esa
alternativa de generar una segunda
oportunidad se volvió para nosotros hoy
una bandera y es el programa y es la
propuesta y es el modo de acompañar
víctimas desmovilizados y jóvenes ex
pandilleros que pasaron de una lógica de
la total dependencia en el caso de
muchos de ellos del estado o de la total
vinculación a la ilegalidad a una lógica
empezar a hacer ciudadanos y eso pasó a
partir del momento en el que esta ciudad
empieza a tener
un organismo establecido específicamente
para trabajar por la paz y la cultura
ciudadana la tarea es inmensa
todos los días tenemos situaciones que
nos muestran que los caleños como que no
entendemos que la ciudad es nuestra y
entonces si no la cuidamos no podemos
pretender que el estado lo haga todo
pero también les quiero contar que hoy
cali tiene 510 seres humanos
que están convirtiéndose en quienes
transfieren mensajes educación y
pedagogía alrededor de la paz de la
convivencia y de la cultura ciudadana
hemos disminuido en un 53 por ciento el
homicidio entre pandillas estamos
trabajando de manera integrada con otros
organismos y con muchas organizaciones
con más de 15.500 jóvenes ex pandilleros
y todavía pandillero resocializar una
persona no es una cosa que se haga de un
día para otro es una cosa que toma
tiempo es una cosa que requiere un
proceso integral de acompañamiento cuál
es ese proceso ahí están los psicólogos
que son fundamentales en este caso
particular nosotros trabajamos con el
arte para que efectivamente se convierta
en un mecanismo terapéutico de
transformación y trabajamos de manera
muy importante con un concepto y es el
concepto que además se trabajó mucho en
esta universidad de justicia
restaurativa porque porque entonces en
lugar de yo ir a la cárcel a pagar
de manera no necesariamente clara por
una por un daño que cometí
yo estoy retribuyendo con acciones
concretas a mi ciudad por los daños que
he cometido y en donde se los encuentran
seguramente algunos de ustedes los han
visto en los puntos más críticos de esta
ciudad en la estación universidades del
mío siempre los van a ver tienen
camiseta azul chaleco café gorra que
dice g de gestor son víctimas ex
combatientes y ex pandilleros y hoy
están todos los días en esta ciudad en
nuestra ciudad en su ciudad diciéndole a
las personas en el mío señora si hacemos
la fila
probablemente nos rinde más el ingreso
están en los puntos de intersección vial
donde hay mayor índice de accidentalidad
enseñándole a la gente la importancia de
educar al peatón
94% de los usuarios que tienen relación
con estas personas manifiestan sentirse
satisfechos porque porque resulta que no
nos habíamos dado cuenta que por ejemplo
en el sistema de transporte masivo no
hay quien acompañe a las personas que
tienen una condición de discapacidad
ellos espontáneamente empezaron a
hacerlo y terminaron convirtiéndose casi
que no en una necesidad tu presencia
para poder movilizar y acompañar a las
personas en situación de discapacidad
tenemos más de mil 333 jornadas de
retribución pero más allá de las cifras
que no es lo importante que yo se las
muestro porque muchos de ustedes seguro
no tenían ni idea que cali tiene una
secretaria de paz y cultura ciudadana y
que tiene un equipo y que tiene 1000 que
tiene 500 gestores de paz tratando de
restablecer las y el civismo que nos
caracterizó como ciudad yo se los cuento
porque básicamente cuando a mí me
invitan a estar acá y me hablan de
viviendo interacciones
yo les digo que la el mensaje que yo
quiero transmitir es el mensaje de lo
que implica una segunda oportunidad
nuestro país es un país que requiere
oportunidades requiere segundas
oportunidades
no podemos seguir matándonos entre
nosotros y no podemos seguir
desconociendo que tenemos una
problemática social inmensa producto de
toda esa historia de dolor de violencia
y conflicto
los jóvenes que finquen en el territorio
son jóvenes consecuencia directa de lo
que fue y de lo que ha sido la historia
del narcotráfico en nuestra ciudad pero
tenemos que sacarlos de allí y sacarlos
de allí implica un ejercicio y una tarea
de todos
esta frase que les voy a leer a
continuación la dijo de manera verbal y
la afortunadamente la registramos un
gestor de paz durante su graduación
porque el tiempo del programa para ellos
tiene un es finito tiene un principio y
tiene un final se trata de no generar
lógicas asistencialistas y su frase fue
las manos que antes hacían daño ahora
son para estudiar para progresar
agradezco por las enseñanzas y al equipo
de acompañamiento artístico y social por
la oportunidad ya no tendrá el uniforme
pero soy gestor de paz y cultura
ciudadana en mi corazón
estos son caleños conviven con nosotros
el mensaje o el cierre simplemente que
yo quiero darles y esta es una frase que
le pertenece a una entidad pública del
gobierno nacional pero que viene como
anillo al dedo es que realmente en
colombia y en cali una oportunidad lo
cambia todo ojalá lo pensemos cuando
estemos en la calle y ojalá nos demos
cuenta que también está en nuestras
manos muchas gracias